que je vous disais mais chers collègues
et Messieurs nos invités et monsieur le
rapporteur et toutes les personnes
présentes merci d'être à nos côtés pour
pour cette mission d'information sur la
gestion durable de l'eau nous recevons
donc aujourd'hui Monsieur Thierry
Thierry caquet directeur scientifique de
l'Institut national de recherche pour
l'agriculture l'alimentation et
l'environnement l'inrae accompagnée de
Monsieur Marc gaucher conseillé pour les
relations parlementaires et
institutionnelles cette audition
plénière fait l'objet d'une
retransmission et d'un compte-rendu
officiel
j'excuse le président Rémy pintro qui
m'a demandé d'assurer la présidence de
notre réunion aux côtés de notre
rapporteur Hervé gihier nous souhaitions
entendre l'inrae car nous nous
interrogeons sur les possibilités de
faire face aux conséquences sur l'eau du
changement climatique en mobilisant
davantage la recherche et l'innovation
la recherche doit nous aider pour mieux
anticiper les phénomènes mais aussi pour
trouver des solutions faire évoluer les
variétés cultivées les techniques
d'irrigation peut-être aussi mieux gérer
l'infiltration de l'eau la retenir quand
cela est possible recycler les eaux
usées la technique ne peut pas tout
faire la technique ne peut pas tout
faire mais peu beaucoup d'ailleurs dans
l'histoire les civilisations ont toutes
changées à chercher à organiser l'accès
à l'eau et on construit des
infrastructures hydrauliques pour faire
face aux difficultés mais le changement
climatique oblige à faire évoluer nos
modèles comment faire en sorte de ne pas
être pris de cours par les sécheresses
ou à l'inverse les pluies diluviennes
avant de vous laisser un temps de 5 à 10
minutes pour un propos introductif
je passe la parole à notre rapporteur
qui vous a adressé une liste de
questions qui pourront guider nos
échanges merci messieurs
merci madame la Présidente mes propos
introductifs sont assez bref on vous a
transmis la liste des questions on est
effectivement dans un moment particulier
à la fois de travaux parlementaires et
de déclarations politiques et
gouvernementales
avec un sujet qui a pris une résonance
en termes de communication
assez forte
malheureusement contenu des sécheresse
hivernales qui étaient constatée
je serai particulièrement attentif au
niveau de notre audition sur
aujourd'hui la qualité on va dire en
même temps de l'accompagnement sur
l'évolution et les nouveaux process mais
derrière ces démarches là de quelle
manière la recherche
et les objectifs d'accompagnement sont
aujourd'hui incarnés et notamment entre
la recherche appliquée et la recherche
fondamentale le sentiment que
il y a un manque de lisibilité
aujourd'hui entre le secteur public et
privé et on a du mal à discerner de
quelle manière
les grands les résultats en même temps
de la recherche et les objectifs sont
vraiment partagés à l'échelle des
territoires les grands territoires les
régions bien sûr en accompagnement
ensuite avec les opérateurs régionaux et
départementaux les chambres de
l'agriculture et autres acteurs
importants dans dans ce domaine donc
j'aurai l'occasion sans doute d'y
revenir et de rebondir je vais vous
laisser rapidement la parole bien sûr
pour vous présenter
brièvement et puis rentrer dans dans le
vif du sujet les premières parties de
questions portaient bien sûr sur
les prélèvements
la question de la sobriété et au travers
du plan haut qu'elles étaient vos
regards volontaires de mise en oeuvre et
de mise en pratique l'analyse de la
géographie
des territoires avec des tensions
maintenant de plus en plus fortes sur
certains qui nécessitent aujourd'hui des
adaptations sans doute à mettre en œuvre
assez assez rapidement
sur les consommations on va déjà
démarrer déjà sur ces premiers champs et
puis on va dérouler je vous en prie
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames messieurs donc
quelques mots pour me présenter donc
Thierry claquet vous l'avez dit je suis
le directeur scientifique environnement
d'inraey nous sommes trois directions
scientifiques dans l'institut et le
portefeuille d'activités pour lequel je
suis mandaté par le collège de direction
concerne le changement climatique vu
sous l'angle de l'adaptation changement
climatique mais aussi de l'aténation du
changement climatique les deux ne vont
pas l'un sans l'autre les questions de
biodiversité les questions de gestion
durable des ressources en eau et en sol
et les questions plus généralement des
risques à faire aux pratiques agricoles
ce qui explique ma présence aujourd'hui
devant cette commission peut-être pour
une introduction très brève revenir sur
le fait que le changement climatique
alors c'est plus une vue de l'esprit
c'est quelque chose qui nous affecte
dans notre quotidien qui a fait toutes
nos activités et il va se manifester ce
changement climatique de plusieurs
façons il y a bien sûr des changements
tendanciel que l'on a en tête quand on
voit les courbes d'évolution de la
concentration CO2 atmosphérique et
l'évolution de la température c'est
parce que le GIA qui a mis en évidence
très longtemps et puis ce qui est plutôt
l'objet de notre interaction aujourd'hui
c'est l'augmentation de la fréquence et
de l'intensité des aléas alors
maintenant et météorologiste que l'on
voit c'est des phénomènes
météorologiques mais qui traduisent une
altération du climat et ça veut dire
peut-être davantage de période de
sécheresse plus prolongée plus fréquente
et de manière j'irai pas symétrique mais
de manière parallèle une augmentation
peut-être de période avec des excès
d'eau vous l'avez mentionné dans votre
propos liminaire et puis plus
globalement ce que ce à quoi
l'agriculture et toutes les activités
humaines et tous les écosystèmes il n'y
a pas que les systèmes humains qui sont
confrontés qui qui nous impactent c'est
la variabilité qui augmente spatialement
et dans le temps donc des conditions
plus variables qui vont nécessiter vous
l'avez dit
une capacité d'adaptation renouvelée et
surtout une difficulté à prendre des
décisions dans un futur de plus en plus
incertain ce qui est très difficile
notamment quand on est dans une activité
économique et en particulier en
agriculture alors dans quand je contexte
là une question qu'on peut se poser
c'est effectivement aussi là on est plus
sobre sur l'usage de l'eau par exemple
avec des protocoles ou des instruments
d'irrigation plus économes en eau
puisqu'il en existe passé par exemple de
l'aspersion au goutte à goutte permet
d'économiser 20 30 40 % de l'eau est-ce
que ça suffit pour passer cette période
difficile que nous connaissons et en
fait le la vision que l'on porte au
niveau de l'Institut et que c'est
quelque chose qui ne suffira pas ça fait
partie d'adaptation c'est ce qu'on
appelle souvent de l'adaptation
incrémentale c'est-à-dire qu'on a juste
des pratiques c'est ce qui a toujours
fait l'agriculture depuis 10000 ans
qu'elle existe mais ce n'est plus
suffisant dans un monde qui change et ça
nous amène à penser différemment la
répartition des activités agricoles
peut-être au niveau du territoire la
nature de ces activités agricoles parce
que le fait de par exemple recourir à
une irrigation renforcée et quelle que
soit la ressource en eau que l'on
utilise c'est de plus en plus considéré
et observer c'est pas qu'une ville
d'esprit comme une démarche dite de mal
adaptation
c'est à dire que dans un climat qui
continue à évoluer et avec des aléas
climatiques de plus en plus fort on a
finalement une fausse impression de
sécurité en sécurisant des ressources en
eau et qui empêche de penser la
transformation des activités agricoles
et des autres activités économiques il y
a des exemples de plus en plus fréquents
rapportés dans la littérature quand vous
prenez le dernier rapport du GIEC des
exemples qui viennent de Chine et puis
plus proche de nous des étangs qui
viennent de l'Espagne avec une stratégie
de développement de l'offre en eau qui a
été faite avec beaucoup d'installations
vous évoquiez madame la Présidente les
infrastructures qui certes sont
indispensables et on aura à faire des
efforts en France en termes
d'infrastructure mais basé une politique
d'adaptation uniquement sur une
augmentation de l'offre à un moment
donné
se retrouve à terme dans une situation
très difficile puisque s'il n'y a plus
d'eau s'il y a plus de précipitations au
moins de précipitations ces systèmes ne
servent à rien puisqu'il y a plus d'eau
à amener au niveau des parcelles donc
infrastructure oui sécurisation de l'eau
oui mais c'est attention à ce qu'on
appelle parfois en économie
[Musique]
peu riche qui retiennent peu l’eau ce
qu'on appelle souvent les zones
intermédiaires ou le croissant des
renzin de ce qu'on disent les géologues
ou là on a des productivités agricoles
assez faibles spontanément qu'on a
renforcé avec de l'irrigation localement
mais qui se trouve vraiment en grande
difficulté dans un climat qui change
donc des régions qui vont devoir se
poser des questions qui est d'ores et
déjà se posent des questions sur
s'engage-t-on dans une d'adaptation on
va dire de conservation coûte que coûte
où est-on dans une logique de
transformation et dans les démarches que
nous poursuivons avec nos partenaires ou
vous évoquiez monsieur le rapporteur nos
partenaires de la Recherche et
Développement et puis les champs de
l'agriculture les instituts techniques
et bien on est dans une logique de
transformer l'agriculture avec une
augmentation de la diversité par exemple
des cultures mises en place une vision
différente du parcellaire de la gestion
des paysages pour retenir davantage
l'eau lorsqu'il y a de l'eau la lui
permettre de s'infiltrer parce que la
meilleure réserve en eau que l'on peut
reconstituer c'est l'eau qui est sous
nos pieds bon ça paraît banal de le dire
mais ralentir le cycle de l'eau qui a
été accéléré par exemple
identificialisation par un certain
nombre de gérer d'actions humaines c'est
quelque part une mesure sans regret
parce que ça permet de réinfiltrer de
l'eau que l'on va pouvoir utiliser
ensuite pour différents usages
l'agriculture c'est en gros 3 milliards
de mètres cubes d'eau au prélever chaque
année sur les 33 milliards de mètres
cubes en moyenne que l'on prélève pour
les activités humaines mais c'est aussi
de l'eau qui peut servir à d'autres
activités et ce qui nous amène un
premier peut-être premier élément de
aussi de discussion possible c'est que
fait-on à l'échelle des territoires quel
est le projet de territoire quand on va
raisonner cette adaptation est-ce que
c'est un territoire qui doit rester
uniquement agricole si oui avec quel
production doit-on maintenir coûte que
coûte la production viticole dans
certaines régions par exemple parce que
la vigne elle-même qui est une espèce
très résistante a besoin d'eau donc ça
pose un vrai question et puis lorsqu'on
fait de la production agricole quelle
valeur ajoutée produit-on pour le
territoire est-ce que cette valeur
ajoutée elle est produite ailleurs
finalement quand on exporte des matières
premières végétales pour faire de
l'alimentation animale ou les aliments
sont fabriqués ailleurs ils reviennent
après pour de l'élevage donc toutes ces
questions à la fois d'impact économique
mais aussi d'impact environnemental
doivent guider des projets de territoire
alors la loi prévoit les projets de
territoire pour la gestion de l'eau ça
me PT ge donc tout le monde a entendu
parler on a beaucoup parlé aux assises
de l'eau on en a reparlé au varen de la
de l'eau et on a reparlé au moment de
lancement du Plan haut mais ça fait
partie de ces réflexions collectives et
incarnées dans les territoires que l'on
doit accompagner et je terminerai
peut-être pour ce propos liminaire sur
le point que vous évoquiez monsieur le
rapporteur sur le lien entre finalement
la connaissance fondamentale que nous
générons dans un organisme comme une Rae
mais aussi notre devoir de recherche
finalisé en appui à l'agriculture et aux
autres activités humaines et à la
gestion des écosystèmes c'est que nous
ne sommes pas seuls dans cette logique
là alors peut-être que c'est pas visible
où on y reviendra c'est possible mais en
tout cas nous déployons sur ce sujet là
comme sur d'autres des actions communes
avec nos partenaires des instituts
techniques agricoles notamment alors les
termes sont un peu techniques mais c'est
une réalité de la vie de nos unités ça
peut être des unités mixtes
technologiques donc partager avec un
institut technique alors cette Arval
dans les grandes cultures l'insuffis
français de la ligne du vin pour la
viticulture je pensais deux exemples là
mais il y en a plein d'autres sur
l'élevage aussi ça peut être des réseaux
mixtes technologiques là qui sont plutôt
des on va dire des des signes tanks on
met en commun des connaissances et des
questions pour proposer des projets de
recherche finalisés par exemple dans les
appels d'offres du casda ou dans
d'autres types de financement et puis
c'est de manière plus concrète et
peut-être plus opérationnelle mais
certes insuffisamment visible et
sûrement à renforcer un dispositif qu'on
l'a mis en place maintenant depuis je
pense 4 à 5 ans partager entre inrae
lakta et les champs de l'agriculture
France qui est une cellule qu'on appelle
la cellule recherche innovation
transfert ou des agents des trois
établissements ou des trois partenaires
travaillent ensemble pour porter la
connaissance des agriculteurs notamment
un certain nombre de gérer d'outils
d'aide à la décision de gestion dans le
domaine qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui
donc tout va bien non attendez j'ai pas
fini
je vais revenir
il y a en fait il y a deux choses il y a
la connaissance elle existe elle est
mobilisable elle commence à être
mobilisé je reviens sur la cellule
recherche innovation transfert dans le
cadre du varen de l'eau nous avons
travaillé avec nos collègues de Lacta
avec nos collègues des chambres
d'agriculture pour produire un guide des
éléments de guide pour les agriculteurs
pour l'adaptation au changement
climatique notamment vu sous l'angle de
la ressource en eau et c'était bien
avant la sécheresse de 2022 puisque les
premiers documents sont sortis au tout
début fin 2021 tout début 2022 ce
document c'est une infographie c'est de
la connaissance si les gens ne se
l'approprient pas ça s'impose une
question et là on va pas assez loin
deuxième élément pour aller un cran plus
loin c'est les actions qui sont en cours
de réflexion vous êtes vraisemblablement
au courant sur le projet de Pâques et de
loi d'orientation agricole qui est porté
par le ministre de l'Agriculture ou
trois groupes de travail ont été mis en
place dont l'un est coupé par Philippe
mauquin directeur général d'inrae pour
justement travailler sur comment
accompagne-t-on l'installation des
nouveaux agriculteurs à une époque où
plus un tiers de ces agriculteurs va
être va partir à la retraite il y a plus
beaucoup ils partent de plus en plus ils
partent malheureusement à la retraite et
donc les nouveaux arrivants comment leur
permettons de se projeter dans un monde
inquiétant parfois anxiogène quand
j'interviens sur ces sujets me dit vous
êtes anxiogène mais il faut pas se où
aller la face dans un monde incertain en
donnant des éléments
factuels des éléments quantifiés des
éléments de stratégie pour construire
leur propre stratégie d'exploitation et
ça ça commence dès la formation dans les
lycées agricoles et dans tout
l'accompagnement qu'on veut qu'on
souhaite mettre en place avec le conseil
agricole avec les instituts techniques
et les chambres alors effectivement je
vous rejoins sur le fait de dire que on
a peut-être toutes les briques on a un
peu une idée des plans de la maison que
l'on veut construire avec ces briques et
ce qui nous manque peut-être c'est
j'irai la maîtrise d'ouvrage pour
vraiment construire cette la maîtrise
d'oeuvre pour construire cette maison et
la rente et j'irai habitable et vivable
je m’interdererais là si vous voulez
qu'on peut peut-être commencer à aborder
le champ des questions c'est plus
important je pense
oui quand même mais il faut tirer ça au
clair jusqu'au bout sur les liaisons
avec les conseils régionaux aujourd'hui
qui sont donc en capacité de pouvoir
accompagner les évolutions de certains
process technologiques industriels et
agricoles en l'occurrence et ce qu'il y
a là des passerelles mises en place qui
sont aujourd'hui suffisamment efficaces
on voit des différenciations dans la
levée des fonds européens aujourd'hui et
dans la stratégie régionale les
stratégies régionales dans ce cas de
figure certaines d'entre elles
fait bien les conditions
d'accompagnement notamment des filières
agricoles et notamment sur les
problématiques d'irrigation d'autres non
donc on voit qu'il y a des variations
territoriales qui sont importantes
peut-être quelques éléments
métropolitain a ultramarin puisque nous
sommes présents aussi aux Antilles et en
Guyane et nous travaillons avec toutes
les régions qui nous souhaitent bien
travailler avec avec inray alors quand
je dis nous travaillons qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire que nous avons
mis en place depuis plus d'une quinzaine
d'années des programmations conjoines
avec les régions ou inrae apporte outre
ses compétences des ressources
financières qui sont équilibrées par des
contributions des régions
et donc ce sont des plans des plans je
dirais pluris annuels de programmation
de la recherche finalisée très finalisée
et le nouvel outil que nous avons lancé
maintenant depuis deux ans s'appelle
tetrae alors ça ne veut rien dire enfin
ça veut dire ça faisait qu'une pas dans
un acronyme mais c'est vraiment des
négociations de gré à gré avec les
conseils régionaux et donc les porteurs
de la politique de recherche et
développement dans ces régions pour
co-construire des projets de Recherche
pour le Développement rural et
territorial vous avez un document de
synthèse sur le sujet alors on pourra on
pourra vous faire parvenir effectivement
la plaquette de présentation du
prototype a démarré je vais pas dire de
bêtises mais il y a deux ans donc on
commence à avoir une liste de projets
qui démarre donc on n'a pas de bilan
mais ça fait suite à 4 actions de même
type pluriannuelles sur lesquels
beaucoup de projets de recherche ont été
co-financés en général c'est un euro mis
par inrae et 1 euro en fait donc si on
parle de quelque chose de 1 à 2 millions
d'euros par an
un euro par les régions certaines
régions vont plus loin sur le
lieu-disantes mais deux ou trois euros
pour 1 euro une Rae et avec
effectivement une thématisation qui
n'était pas forcément axée sur le
changement climatique dans les
programmes il y a 12 ans 13 ans 14 ans
mais qui sur la campagne en cours sont
beaucoup de projets en lien avec
l'adaptation au changement climatique
dans différentes régions alors toutes
les régions n'ont pas géré forcément
spontanément à la démarche l'idée c'est
d'avoir de créer un peu des pilotes et
que ça devienne quelque chose de plus de
plus général l'autre approche sur lequel
alors inraine ne peut pas être maître
d'oeuvre mais peut participer et nous
participons à des projets ce sont les
démonstrateurs territoriaux qui ont été
mis en place dans le cadre de France 20
30 on accompagnement avec un nombre de
stratégies d'accélération notamment la
stratégie d'accélération sur le
déploiement de l'agroécologie donc ce
sont des projets qui de fait doivent
être portés par des collectivités
locales et territoriales ou des acteurs
des territoires donc inray apporte ses
compétences scientifiques en termes de
recherche R&D expertise sur par exemple
la mise à disposition d'outils la
définition de d'outils d'intermédiation
avec des acteurs et ça c'est des choses
sur lesquelles nous ne pouvons pas être
pilote puisque la loi entre guillemets
le réglementation nous interdit mais
nous sommes partenaires et puis l'autre
troisième dispositif alors qu'il y a un
peu antérieur et celui des territoires
d'innovation on a appelé pendant
longtemps des territoires d'innovation
de grande ambition montant le territoire
d'innovation je prends un exemple alors
qui est pas forcément sur l'adaptation
au changement climatique tel qu'on le
voit aujourd'hui dans cette interaction
mais qui est plus sur comment un
territoire s'empare de la question de sa
son approvisionnement alimentaire dans
une logique de diversification de
sécurisation c'est le territoire de la
métropole de Dijon donc Dijon métropole
nous avons une action dans lequel nous
chercheurs du Centre de inrail de Dijon
sont très impliqués sur justement
comment on déploie l'échelle d'un
territoire la transition agroécologique
des productions agricoles dans un but à
la fois de sécurisation de la production
agricole et de qualité des productions
alimentaires pour les citoyens du
territoire
non les pâtes c'est des plusieurs
échelles on est des collègues qui
travaillaient avec les porteurs de pâtes
la Dijon c'est un peu plus grand qu'un
pattes mais c'est un peu l'idée
maintenant il y a pas de les pâtes
c'est l'ensemble du territoire
on a tous à utiliser nos propres
acronymes c'est toujours un peu un peu
délicat donc c'est une vision pixelisée
mais on ne peut pas être bien sûr
présent partout l'idée c'est d'être en
capacité et c'est pour ça qu'on a cette
cellule innovation transfert et qu'on
déploie des outils on va dire aussi de
diffusion de la connaissance de mise à
disposition de la connaissance sur
toutes nos données produite sont des
données ouvertes toutes nos publications
à partir du moment où elles sont
financées sur des ressources publiques
sont des publications ouvertes ce qui
manque vraisemblablement et je vous
rejoins c'est la capacité à démultiplier
et à engager la transformation à grande
échelle pour un grand nombre
d'exploitants agricoles
et peut-être pour terminer sur ce point
en tout cas à ce niveau de la discussion
on parle depuis tout à l'heure moi le
premier de production
différentes productions diversification
mais ce qui doit se mettre en place
c'est pas simplement une transformation
des activités à l'échelle des
exploitations des exploitants agricoles
c'est vraiment les chaînes de valeur
associées qui doivent être
capable de s'adapter à des nouvelles
productions plus diverses différentes
qui rencontrent finalement enfin qui
s'articule avec des transformateurs avec
des distributeurs et des consommateurs
vous parliez de l'application des
régions je prends un exemple très
concret dans lequel inrae a participé
sur une période à peu près 10 ans au
déploiement à l'installation d'une
nouvelle filière agricole en région
sud-ouest dans le région toulousaine en
Occitanie avec l'agence de l'eau à
bourg-garonne avec l'agence dodo revue
Méditerrané Corse avec le Conseil
régional d'Occitanie c'est une filière
de légumineuses à graines un
légumeineuse je passais tout moi ce que
c'est ce sont des plantes qui sont un
peu magiques alors les légumes
désagrément c'est pois chiches lentilles
et c'est des bonnes ça intéressant comme
culture c'est d'abord c'est assez
économe en eau en tout cas sur une
saison de culture et puis ce sont des
plantes qui se passent d'un train azoté
d'engrais azoté puisqu'elle fixe l'azote
de l'air et donc la mise en place de
cette filière elle a pris à peu près une
dizaine d'années mais ça veut dire qu'il
faut être capable d'aller jusqu'à la
distribution à la marque mais c'est un
accompagnement de l'ensemble récepteur
c'est la région ce sont les deux agences
de l'eau qui elles ont des
préoccupations à la fois sur la quantité
de la ressource mais la qualité aussi de
la ressource et donc qui ont mis en
place cette filière de légumineuses donc
une règle apporter son savoir-faire sur
l'agronomie sur la gestion des sols la
gestion de l'eau mais aussi sur la
vision économique de ce développement
puisque le producteur comme le
transformateur comme le distributeur est
un acteur économique et donc il doit
vivre de son activité et donc la
transformation de la chaîne de chaîne de
valeur est obligatoire dans cette
logique d'adaptation c'est pas
uniquement le niveau de la production
qui doit évoluer s'il y a pas le marché
ça marche pas
mais par exemple
quand il y a des nouvelles filières qui
se mettent en place à peu près ça fait
10 ans moi je suis en Champagne crayeuse
anciennement Champagne pouilleuse donc
il faut vraiment beaucoup de beaucoup
d'arrosage pour pour que pour qu'on ait
des rendements intéressants et là on
faisait uniquement
c'était toutes les céréales et depuis
une dizaine d'années c'est la filière
pomme de terre il faut énormément d'eau
et ça sur la craie je veux dire ça fixe
pas du tout et il y a des entreprises
qui sont venues s'installer la
transformation qu'est-ce que ça va
devenir parce qu'il faut vraiment
beaucoup d'eau et tous les agriculteurs
dans le secteur sont partis dans la
pomme de terre vous décrivez je pense
une une situation que malheureusement on
peut on peut transposer dans pas mal pas
mal de régions c'est qu'effectivement à
partir du moment un outil industriel une
production à vocation industrielle je
vais l'appeler comme ça et c'est pas
péjoratif quand je parle de production
industrielle qui est une culture sous
contrat c'est à dire que l'agriculteur
s'engage à produire tel qualité pour les
pommes de terre bon tout le monde
entendu parler dans la sécheresse 2020
tout le monde comme beaucoup de gens en
tout cas de des conflits entre un grand
industriel de la pomme de terre que je
ne nommerai pas je verrai de publicité
clandestine et puis les producteurs de
pommes de terre dans les hauts de France
ou finalement les pommes de terre
livrées étaient inférieurs aux calibres
de ce qui était dans le contrat de vente
certaines productions ont été refusées
parce que de taille inférieure ou
acheter à ville prix puisque c'était
hors du cahier des charges de voilà bah
voilà donc et donc ça ça veut dire que
si on réfléchit en se projetant à 2030
même oui 2030 c'est demain maintenant
c'est un très très vite et un peu
au-delà c'est pas simplement le choix de
la production qui doit être fait mais
c'est le cahier des cahier des charges
qu'on y associe et c'est le
dimensionnement et l'évolution de
l'outil industriel qui est derrière
alors vous pourrez me dire il y a
peut-être des gens qui vont considérer
que si on peut plus produire dans votre
région dans d'autres régions les
produits ailleurs
il faisait d'échappement ça qu'on valait
et ça on sait que ça se produit on sait
qu'il y a une tendance à ça et
vraisemblablement l'une des l'un des
leviers à activer c'est effectivement au
travers de la concertation avec les
filières de pouvoir réfléchir la on
parle beaucoup de réindustrialisation
mais l'évolution de l'outil
agroalimentaire français qui a été très
performant à une période où les
conditions le permettaient depuis gérer
fin des années 50 jusque au début des
années 90 puisque on a commencé dès le
début des années 90 alors des rendements
quand même type plafonnaient pour les
céréales et autres et cet outil qui a
coûté très cher à installer cette hyper
spécialisation de certaines régions moi
j'habite en région Bretagne oui un peu
l'agroalimentaire en Bretagne est-ce que
ça représente en termes je dirais de
poids économique et de contraintes aussi
sur l'environnement et bien c'est toute
cette géographie agroalimentaire qu'il
faudrait pouvoir se permettre de
repenser alors sans être dans la
coercition mais au moins de se projeter
dans des visions différentes et dans vos
questions vous évoquez le fait est-ce
que finalement on peut imaginer des
productions constantes
simplement en ayant un levier
d'adaptation qui est l'eau ma réponse
sera non parce qu'on n'aura pas assez
d'eau partout on en aura besoin pour
adapter les cultures et donc ça veut
dire que outre les évolutions à
l'échelle locale et la réflexion à
l'échelle locale il faut une certaine
planification dans le bon sens du mot
planification de l'évolution de la
géographie agricole de la France si
c'est possible ça paraît un peu
illusoire ou peut-être idéologique je ne
sais pas mais c'est quelque chose sur
lequel il faut en tout cas qu'on se
permette d'avancer parce que le maintien
du statu quo semble extrêmement
difficile pour pas dire impossible pour
l'eau mais aussi pour la qualité des
sols mais aussi pour la pression sur la
biodiversité l'eau n'est donc qu'un des
éléments de bien sûr d'un système
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus complexe
alors dans les questions que vous
abordiez si je peux me permettre de pour
avancer parce que le temps passe vite et
je suis très bavard et vous savez qu'on
a les questions gouvernement à 15h
donc alors juste deux points dans les
points que vous avez abordés je vais les
regrouper il y a quelque chose qu'on
nous présente souvent enfin que certains
présentent souvent comme étant le levier
ou la solution magique c'est
l'amélioration des variétés la
génétiques qui va sauver l'agriculture
on en a beaucoup parlé pendant le varen
de l'eau que j'ai participé en fait
l'amélioration des variétés c'est
quelque chose de continuer depuis des
décennies
avec des outils différents mais on
continue finalement à choisir les
meilleurs variétés etc donc ça apporte
des solutions ponctuelles mais c'est
qu'un élément de la solution il faut
vraiment le combiner avec plein d'autres
outils la diversification
avec un travail du sol différent etc
donc la génétique peut faire des choses
mais elle ne peut pas tout et ça me
permet de placer un slogan mais un des
éléments que j'aime rappeler quand
j'interviens sur ce genre de sujet c'est
qu'il faut éviter de faire croire
certaines personnes mal informées que
l'on peut faire pousser des plantes sans
eau
de manière totalement qu'elle soit une
plante l'intérêt agronomique ou une
plante sauvage elle a besoin d'eau pour
pousser faire ce qu'on appelle de la
biomasse donc de la croissance et faire
des graines des fleurs des graines si
c'est une plante à fleurs
pourquoi parce que finalement
toutes les plantes fonctionnent avec un
même mécanisme vivant que la
photosynthèse que nous n'avons pas elle
respire comme nous mais elles ont en
plus la photosynthèse qui leur permet à
partir du flux d'eau qui part des
racines vers l'atmosphère au travers des
feuilles au niveau des feuilles
notamment en général sous l'action du
rayonnement solaire en présence de CO2
et bien on a production de sucre on a
souvent appris ça à l'école quand on C3
les plantes en C4 pendant le détail en
forme de sucre ça forme de la biomasse
ça forme des réserves de la plante une
plante qui vit dans le désert elle
fonctionne comme ça comme du maïs comme
de la luzerne simplement la quantité
d'eau disponible les variables ce qui
fait qu'une plante qui a pas beaucoup
d'eau à sa disposition alors après on
stocker dans ces tissus à tout juste de
l'Aloe l'aloe vera les tissus etc sont
tricher en eau mais s'il y a pas d'eau
pendant plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années la plante va peut-être végéter
mais ne va pas pousser pas se développer
donc même une plante désertique a besoin
d'eau à un moment donné ne serait-ce que
pour fleurir vu des images de désert
après une pluie tout toutes les plantes
fleuries se produisent leurs graines
parce que pendant des années ils ont pas
pu le faire y compris dans le désert de
Kama ou au Pérou donc pour qu'il y ait
de la production de matières vivantes
donc de biomasse notamment agricole mais
c'est vrai pour les arbres aussi il faut
de l'eau il faut de la lumière solaire
et il faut du CO2 pour la plupart des
plantes c'est comme ça que ça marche
donc sans eau pas de production
alimentaire donc ça c'est un invariant
c'est les plantes qui nous imposent ça
et à partir de là donc ce qu'il faut
imaginer c'est quelle plante quelle
culture à quel endroit en fonction de ce
qu'on en a comme ressources en eau
pour l'instant est-ce qu'on prévoit
comme ressources en eau dans le futur et
c'est là qu'on se pose des questions sur
quels seront les endroits favorables
pour telle ou telle plante en fonction
de ses besoins en eau donc il y avait
des questions je prends dans les
chiffres je pense qu'on voulait
communiquera mais les besoins en eau
sont très différents selon le type de
sol selon la température donc c'est
difficile de dire il faut tant de
millimètres d'eau pour le maïs ou temps
de mm d'eau par an pour le blé on sait
simplement qu'avec enfin on sait donc
les chiffres qui circulent le plus
souvent c'est que à l'heure actuelle il
faut à peu près la même quantité d'eau
pour faire 100 kg de grains de maïs ou
100 kg de grains de blé simplement et
c'est parfois même un peu plus d'eau
pour le blé que pour le maïs mais c'est
pas la même période de l'année donc
avoir des espèces qui fleurissent plutôt
ou là enfin en tout cas quand on n'est
pas quand on comme cette année avec une
sécheresse printanière très forte ça
peut être intéressant de la même manière
on présente souvent le sorgho comme
étant une plante qui pourrait remplacer
et qui va remplacer le maïs c'est vrai
ça peut être vrai dans certaines régions
alors faut être honnête et là on parle
pas des limites aussi y compris de la
recherche agronomique il y a eu beaucoup
plus
[Musique]
qui se permettent qu'ils puissent
continuer à produire même dans des
conditions qui sont devenues assez
défavorables et en ayant une production
qui à la fin peut être vendue et
consommée et je terminerai peut-être sur
la ligne des questions puis après il y a
peut-être d'autres questions qui vont
mettre posées sur la partie
réutilisation des eaux usées ça il y a
beaucoup d'éléments dans votre
questionnaire puisque c'est apparu on en
a commencé on a commencé à parler en
2018-2019 dans les assises de l'eau on
en a reparlé en disant on va multiplier
par trois voilà trois fois pas grand
chose ça fait pas grand chose toujours
alors les freins bah si vous la je vous
calez sur quatre freins principaux
les normes sanitaire moi je veux dire
comme ça avec donc le décret européen
qui est en application qui passe en
apparition de la loi française à partir
du mois de mai cette année j'ai pu la
dette exacte mais avant ça sera mieux
que moi il y a un décret qui encadre
lieu la réutilisation des eaux usées
traités qui est sorti alors en Europe en
2020 et qui est en application voilà la
française en 2023 et qui semble être à
la fois dans le détail plus plus
drastique que ce que propose la RS donc
vous allez dire ça pas forcément dans le
bon sens
j'y reviendrai j'ai pas forcément tout
en tête dans mes notes le deuxième point
c'est un problème technique parce que
c'est tout à traiter oui
à partir de des eaux bien sûr la pomme
de terre primeur de Noirmoutier c'est
l'exemple que tout le monde utilise
de Ré Noirmoutier et puis ça commence à
se développer dans certains territoires
du Sud
partout
[Musique]
incompréhensible qui sont pas lancés
comme il faudrait alors peut-être un
frein dont on parle moins parce qu'il
est beaucoup plus difficile à
appréhender c'est la perception
c'est à dire vous êtes un consommateur
et on a des collègues à Montpellier qui
travaillent sur ces aspects là à la fois
que des étudiants de
l'agronomie Montpellier donc ils sont au
fait quand même de la question qui sont
censés être éclairés je pense que ça
veut dire mais connaître les tenants
aboutissants de la question avec des
viticulteurs avec des agriculteurs quand
vous posez la question à des gens sur le
principe théorique seriez-vous prêts à
acheter cette salade ce vin produit avec
une irrigation à base de haut usées
traité au début quand on vous dit bah ok
oui bien sûr dans le principe je suis
tout à fait d'accord dans le principe
c'est tout à fait d'accord après acte
d'achat on dit bah voilà on vous donne
50 euros c'est l'économie expérimentale
ça vaut ce que ça vaut mais Pic
Saint-Loup je prends je fais pas de
publicité ni pour le vin mais bon le Pic
Saint-Loup un terroir bien connu très
belle appellation voilà et bien
l'affaire des graines bio en Allemagne
avec jeunes 10 ou 15 morts c'est en
partie des questions de qualité
sanitaire de l'eau utilisée pour faire
germer les graines donc c'est pas une
vue de l'esprit puis les épidémies du
choléra au 19e siècle
ah bah
alors les traces de médicaments
si vous voulez les eaux usées qu'on
rejachent exactement dans le milieu
naturel dans la plupart des stations
d'épuration vous n'enlevez pas les
produits phytosanitaires leur
métabolites voire la question de
métabolites de l'herbicides de SOS dans
l'eau du robinet en France c'est un
exemple c'est de l'eau du robinet c'est
pas de l'eau qu'on rejette en rivière
donc imaginez une eau qu'on rejette en
rivière
ce sont les régimes médicaments les
perturbateurs endocriniens peut-être
certains microplastiques donc
décontaminants alors on peut peut-être
les éliminer on peut les on peut les
éliminer il y a une technique qui marche
très bien ça s'appelle l'osmose inverse
le son inverse sauf qu'après il faut
remettre des éléments minéraux dans
l'eau parce que c'est l'eau elle est
plus elle est toxique en fait parce que
l'eau trop pur est toxique donc on a ce
problème là quand même donc c'est un
problème de coute aussi et de coûte de
l'énergie
voilà donc mais c'est pas pour dire
qu'il faut s'en passer c'est comme enfin
si peut-être le dernier mot avant de
répondre à vos questions c'est que il
faut se sortir de l'esprit qu'il y a une
solution un levier unique à tous nos
problèmes c'est forcément des
assemblages voilà c'est une brique parmi
d'autres qui sera valable à l'endroit y
par l'endroit X
[Musique]
la France elle a une particularité quand
même c'est d'être entouré par des eaux
en général il était parti Atlantique la
partie militaire année alors c'est
certainement plus simple de rechercher
des sources de douces à traiter que de
dessaler l'eau de mer mais néanmoins
dans une période où on parle de monter
des océans où on parle de pénurie de
pénurie de douce et c'était il y a des
travaux de recherche qui sont menés dans
cette direction en rétorque souvent que
c'est un problème de coût évidemment
avec une énergie qui nécessaire qui est
importante pour déceler l'eau de mer
mais est-ce que c'est pas une solution
envisagée sur le sur le long terme et
est-ce que vous participez à des travaux
de recherche dans ce domaine particulier
je vais commencer par répondre à la
dernière question la réponse est non
inray n'est pas mobilisé à ma
connaissance qui n'est pas forcément
exhaustive 12000 personnes à une Reich
parce que chacun fait dans son labo mais
j'ai une vision à peu près complète en
fait une reine n'a jamais été à ma
connaissance impliqué dans des travaux
sur le dessalement de l'eau de mer on
est plutôt sur on va dire pour les gens
qui aident dans l'institut du travail
sur ces questions plutôt sur
l'amélioration de la qualité des eaux
usées alors d'une part pour en retirer
peut-être des éléments on va dire
valorisables des engrais par exemple à
partir de phosphore qui sont dans nos
eaux usées améliorer les traitements et
sur l'impact de ces rejets sur les
milieux sur la réutilisation des eaux
usées traitées dans près de Montpellier
à Murviel et Montpellier on a une
installation pilote on teste des
processus on parlait des limites par
exemple on travaille sur le fait que de
l'eau
usée traitée utilisée en irrigation à
l'ancrage les tuyaux d'irrigation c'est
un vrai problème des biofilms qui se
développent des cristallisations qui se
développent on bouche les tuyaux avec de
la réunite qu'on n'a pas avec de l'eau
brute parce que la danse se développe
beaucoup de micro-organismes qui font
des biofilms et qui bougent bon et par
rapport à votre première question sur le
dessalement c'est encore une fois
ponctuellement pourquoi pas sur de
certaines îles antillaises ça se
développe y compris sur les territoires
français sous autorité française bien
sûr il y a la question de que vous
soulevez et qui est une question
cruciale parce que évaporer de l'eau il
faut beaucoup d'énergie alors il y a
l'osmose inverse qui fonctionne mais
après faut reminéraliser l'eau donc ça
rajoute des coûts et puis il y a quand
même qu'est-ce que l'on fait de tout ce
qu'on extrait de l'eau de mer les Saumur
et l'un des principaux
impacts sur l'environnement parce que
jamais oublier l'environnement c'est que
le rejet de ces Saumur ça pose un vrai
problème qu'est-ce qu'on en fait c'est
des concentrations de sel énorme pas
valorisables ou peu valorisable et donc
là on a un impact collatéral de la du
dessalement qui est effectivement une
pollution par des selles qu'on va
épandre à terre ou qu'on va remettre
dans le milieu naturel donc on va créer
des déchets il y a un problème de
pollution alors techniquement on sait
faire les pays du Golfe certains pays du
Golf le développent si l'énergie n'est
pas chère c'est faisable un petit
échelle c'est faisable on pourrait
pourquoi pas imaginer du dessalement
avec et certains y penses je pense en
Australie notamment avec des énergies
renouvelables avec le solaire de
l'éolien et autres
mais il y a quand même tout sur cette
question des saumurs qu'est-ce que l'on
fait de cette de se concentrer de sel
donc ponctuellement pourquoi pas plus
généralement ça me paraît difficilement
envisageable
oui je veux bien vous poser deux
questions la première c'est sur l'osmose
inverse parce que je suis sénateur du
Val-de-Marne et un projet sur sur
l'Île-de-France que j'ai compris de ce
projet c'est que les déchets sont
rejetés en aval
qui évidemment pose un petit problème
parce que au fond on purifie l'eau on
l'a
pollue enfin on l'a reminéralise en
rajoutant de l'eau non traitée mais les
déchets extraits pour des raisons sans
doute de coups sont remis au fond dans
la rivière en aval enfin dans le fleuve
en aval du traitement c'est-à-dire qu'on
renvoie l'eau finalement encore plus
dégradé pour Rouen enfin bon je fais pas
de je veux pas soulever de guerre des
territoires mais j'avoue que
puis je le fais un tout un petit peu
exprès parce que ça m'interroge enfin je
suis un élu métropolitain qui pense au
solidarité nationale et donc ça
m'interroge que on met un milliard pour
traiter l'eau comme ça et renvoyer nos
déchets aux autres c'est un peu comme le
dessalement avec les saumurs donc est-ce
que c'est bien comme ça est-ce que c'est
bien raisonnable de remettre des déchets
et ma deuxième question vous avez parlé
des ptge du travail entre comment mieux
faire connaître vos travaux et partager
vos travaux avec les régions les
décideurs politiques et vous avez parlé
à propos de l'exemple de la pomme de
terre des acteurs économiques et moi je
suis frappé du sentiment que les
agriculteurs sont souvent au fond dans
des pièges parce qu'ils ont des
commandes plus réelles donc si eux
décident de modification et encore
faut-il que l'agro industrie derrière
accepte et participe donc qu'est-ce que
ces acteurs industriels sont dans les
débats sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique et
sur la question d'osmose inverse je
connais pas le faire vaguement entendu
parler du projet ce que vous décrivez
c'est ce que j'ai décrit pour des salons
c'est à qu'on va concentrer des éléments
indésirables au sens large alors ça peut
être des micropollants comme des sels
minéraux naturels et donc si on ne
nettoie pas les membranes ça finit par
s'encrasser et donc on a des déchets et
effectivement il peut y avoir une
tentation de les remettre dans le milieu
naturel j'ai dire si ce sont des
éléments minéraux comme du carbonnade de
calcium du sodium c'est pas très grave
ça va se diluer si ce sont des
contaminants de type produits photo
pharmaceutiques ou médicament ça paraît
je ne mon point de vue je connais pas le
projet dans le détail ça me paraît en
théorie en tout cas quelque chose
d'assez peu recommandable voilà en plus
moi je suis ma formation initiale sur
les côtes toxicologie donc l'impact des
substances chimiques sur les milieux
aquatiques plus on enlève mieux c'est
donc on les remettes plus concentrés en
aval d'une installation ça me paraît pas
du bon sens en tout cas vu de mon point
de vue des collègues et des côtes
toxicologues et la solidarité à Montaval
que vous évoquez quelque part finalement
elle est extrêmement important dans tout
ce qu'on discute ici donc l'adaptation
elle doit pas se raisonner notamment y
compris sur la réutilisation des eaux
usées traitées on pourrait se dire on va
en amont on va récupérer plein d'eau on
va la réutiliser nous et on avale bah
tant pis pour eux ils sont en aval enfin
c'est des débats qui peuvent paraître
comme ça tu peux gérer hors sol or moi
j'ai eu ce type de d'interrogations de
la part de la région Bourgogne
Franche-Comté où ils sont commencé à se
poser des questions sur faut-il
développer la réussite en sur trois
bassins versants en plus trois agences
c'est compliqué en tête de bassin
versant ils ont dit bah non finalement
parce qu'on avale ils vont plus rien à
voir donc ils ont renoncé à certains
projets donc je pense que ce que vous
décrivez est une situation qui me paraît
assez assez critique sur la partie avale
enfin les industries agroalimentaires en
fait elles sont pas complètement enfin
du sera agroalimentaire au sens large
donc tout ce qui va être là à la fois le
l'approvisionnement les le conseil et
puis l'achat la transformation il y a
des volontés d'adaptation alors il y a
deux je pense qu'il y a plusieurs
stratégies et il y a pas eu une
entreprise qui a une stratégie il y a
cette tentation d'aller voir ailleurs si
c'est possible l'échappement que
j'évoquais ça trouve de plus en plus ses
limites parce que le changement
climatique il impacte à peu près partout
quand même et donc d'un point de vue
économique et une certaine rationalité
quand même imaginé comme les solutions
d'abord local mais c'est pas toujours le
cas je n'ai pas de nom à vous donner
mais on peut imaginer qu'il y a des
solutions de facilité de se dire je peux
plus faire tel production
je sais pas de pomme de terre dans le
nord de la France je vais le faire en
Grande-Bretagne on a eu l'exemple c'est
un peu emblématique des vignes que
certains ont commencé à installer en
Angleterre pour faire du champagne on
devrait être à peu près la période où on
peut les récolter maintenant ça fait 10
ans voilà donc à voir mais ça ça existe
et c'est présent quand vous prenez des
projections production de blé ou de de
culture annuelle en 2050 en Europe si
vous êtes un investisseur vous voulez
investir des milliards dans
l'outil agroalimentaire pour le blé faut
pas l'investir en Espagne il faut pas
l'investir au Portugal il faut même pas
l'investir en France
faut l'investir en Pologne en Ukraine
voir en Scandinavie parce que ce sont
des zones qui devraient si les
projections sont toujours des
projections c'est pas des prédictions de
venir sont déjà pour certaines très
productrices il devrait alors production
augmentée et pas être trop impacté par
les conditions du changement climatique
donc ça c'est un élément quand même je
dirais sur le capital et
l'investissement en capital il est
important et corollaire à ça je réponds
pas totalement à question mais je pense
qu'il faut le mentionner ici dans les
réflexions c'est la perte de valeur
foncière des terres qui sont dans les
zones les plus impactées dans le Grand
Sud-Ouest de la France
même les grands vignobles commencent à
avoir des problèmes alors pour
différentes raisons c'est pas que le
changement climatique mais ça peut avoir
un impact non mais si vous prenez enfin
excusez-moi on est sur une surproduction
à l'heure actuelle et donc les problèmes
sont essentiellement liés à la
surproduction pour ça mais si vous
prenez les cartes de l'Agence Européenne
de l'Environnement projection de la
valeur foncière des terres alors c'est
des projections à 2100
vous avez des -40 - 60 - 70 % sur toute
la péninsule ibérique et une grande
moitié sud-ouest de la France qui part
de la Bretagne et qui va jusqu'en PACA
vous pouvez nous les communiquer où on
peut avoir ces données là alors la carte
c'est un rapport de 2019 c'est sur des
projets qui exposés un climat rendement
donc
j'aimerais bien savoir alors sur juste
sur par contre pour vous dire que le
foncier à Bordeaux surtout sur les zones
constructibles a été multipliée par 10
donc
ceux qui ne décident pas de gérer de
d'exporter d'aller chercher ailleurs ils
participent à toutes les discussions que
j'ai évoqué le varen de l'eau tout à
l'heure varen agricole de l'eau de son
changement climatique les industries
agroalimentaires qu'au départ n'était
pas forcément
je serai ciblé par les deux ministères
qui avaient lancé la consultation ont
répondu quand on parle de réalisation
des eaux usées traitées les plus actifs
dans le domaine industriel sur ces
questions sont les industries laitières
pourquoi ne peut-on pas réutiliser et là
vous parler de la RS tout à l'heure les
eaux de lavage en tête pour faire autre
chose que de laver les camions ou
arroser les fleurs devant le siège de
l'entreprise enfin je dis avec des mots
un peu bruts mais c'est un peu ça quand
même et donc il y a une si on veut ils
veulent garder l'emploi local et
l'industrie locale ils sont forcés de se
projeter dans une adaptation alors après
la question va être qui couvre les
investissements
qui aussi assure les risques prix en
maintenant un outil à tel ou tel endroit
et c'est vrai aussi pour la production
agricole qui va assurer les risques d'un
agriculteur ou d'un groupe
d'agriculteurs qui s'engagent dans une
transformation je sur ce niveau là
puisque vous aviez évoqué aussi les
relations avec l'Europe mais pour le
coup c'est une orientation aussi de la
PAC qui doit être aujourd'hui et aussi
ciblée sur ces stratégies là quand vous
parliez d'une nouvelle géographie de
production et notamment de production
alimentaire
elle doit aussi se traduire au travers
de la PAC donc c'est bien aujourd'hui
une rediscution aussi au sein des mêmes
des grands programmes européens pour
accompagner sur une vision européenne
justement les évolutions productives
entièrement d'accord avec vous dans deux
deux éléments de réponse le premier
élément c'est moderne de stratégie
générale c'est le pacte vert
dont on sait qu'il a été énormément
attaqué y compris en interne en Europe y
compris par la profession agricole en
disant vous allez affamer l'Europe et le
monde
charmer la citation et en fait dans ce
pacte vert vous avez quand même la
transition agroécologique la
diversification la limitation d'usage
des intrants et n'ai compris notre en
eau un trou donc qui est quand même à
l'agenda donc ça fait partie de l'agenda
politique et après il y a la Pâques un
outil qui a été
transformant je prends pas de jugement
il a profondément transformé
l'agriculture européenne
voilà avec pour le meilleur et pour le
pire voilà mais en tout cas il y a quand
même ça quand même un effet transponde
ça veut dire qu'un outil de ce type là
c'est pour ça que je pour le côté
positif et potentiellement transformant
à partir du moment où il y a chinois
consensus tout au moins une grande
majorité pour aller dans un certain sens
qui n'est pas le cas de la pacte actuel
et où lorsqu'il y a une partie qui est
laissée à l'appréciation des États
membres le plan stratégique national il
faut que ce plan stratégique national
soit à la hauteur des difficultés
auxquelles nous sommes confrontés celles
qui vont se présenter et on peut
considérer nos collègues d'une certaine
nos collègues d'inray ont beaucoup
travaillé sur cette question du PSN et
sur les différentes mesures qui sont
dedans et quel est la place de la France
finalement dans la course vers
l'adaptation et on peut quand même
raisonnablement écrire et dire on l'a
fait on l'a écrit on l'a dit que le plan
stratégique national français est
insuffisamment ambitieux dans pas mal de
domaines y compris dans le domaine de
l'adaptation au changement climatique
donc je peux pas la prochaine pack on va
commencer enfin on va commencer enfin
commencer à être réfléchie après les
élections du Parlement bien sûr ça va
commencer et donc c'est dès cette
renégociation de la Pâque il faut être
le plus me semble-t-il le plus en avant
sur la transformation et non pas
pérenniser un système qui est de fait un
petit peu prisonnier de lui-même il nous
reste encore quelques minutes on a Jean
Macé
une remarque et une question
il y a une dizaine d'années avec la
société du Canal de Provence on
travaillait à la récupération des eaux
d'une station d'épuration pour irriguer
bon donc notre process qu'on avait mis
en place à démontrer que c'était
envisageable mais par contre pour avoir
l'autorisation il nous fallait faire à
la fin une campagne d'analyse qui nous
coûtait plus de 100.000 euros pour une
petite commune de 300 habitants et on
allait arroser 50 hectares au maximum
qui on n'était pas sûr de pouvoir faire
de
n'importe quoi comme arrosage donc on
avait laissé tomber deux ça c'est et la
question du parliez des saumurs quand on
dessine l'eau est-ce que ce sont mieux
on peut à pas être utilisés l'hiver pour
sur les routes parce que on met des
tonnes et des tonnes de sel pour les
sécuriser quand ça gêne ou quand il
neige alors
votre dernière question je pourrais pas
y répondre j'ai pas d'idée franchement
j'ai pas d'exemples en tête où ça a été
fait mais pourquoi pas après dans un
climat qui change je dis il est probable
que les saumurs ont enfin le salage des
routes sera toujours nécessaire parce
qu'il y aura toujours des du gel sans
doute de moins en moins je sais pas sûr
que les volumes enfin je sais pas je
pourrais pas vous répondre de manière
quantitative et sur le premier remarque
c'est typiquement ce qui a été mis en
évidence dans beaucoup d'analyses je
crois que le céréma notamment avait
Bruce rail là dessus sur un rapport de
2018 sur le développement de la réunite
en France de dire de vouloir faire des
campagnes d'An Alyse de sol avant après
de suivi etc ça implique pour le mettre
d'ouvrage des coûts qui sont
incompatibles avec ce que vous disiez je
partage après où est l'équilibre entre
[Musique]
pas de contrôle et un contrôle trop
enfin vous savez le curseur est
difficile à placer mais ça fait partie
des limites identifiées en tout cas de
la réussite je suis d'accord avec vous
oui
juste avant de conclure
vous pouvez là aujourd'hui nous faire
aussi des propositions de ce dont vous
avez besoin pour aller plus fort et plus
vite et de manière plus efficace c'est
le moment ou jamais donc faites-le
c'était pas dans les questions non je
pense que j'ai un peu abordé la question
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire que il faut
collectivement parce que c'est vraiment
une démarche collective je pense qu'il
faut déplacer le je dirais le la
concentration de l'attention faut pas la
défendre faut pas je réfléchis en même
temps que je parle excusez-moi
la production le secteur amont c'est
important c'est-à-dire qu'il faut donner
les outils aux producteurs pour
s'adapter
c'est pas suffisant ça ne sera jamais
suffisant en tout cas dans un climat qui
change de plus en plus vite ce dont on a
besoin ce sont des politiques publiques
ambitieuses en termes d'accompagnement
et vous des questions sur lesquels pas
revenu et vous aurez quelques éléments
écrits c'était la prospective
agriculture 2050 sans pesticides
outre les leviers donc la
diversification l'immunité végétale etc
ce que les collègues ont ressorti de
leur analyse et c'est une analyse
européenne ce qui est avec des experts
de plusieurs pays européens c'est que
sans politique publique ambitieuse la
pacte en fait partie mais c'est pas que
ça
et bien on ne sortira pas de la du
système où on est le système il est
totalement verrouillé il est verrouillé
par l'histoire il est verrouillé par le
contexte économique le contexte
politique le marché donc il nous faut
des politiques publiques ambitieuses et
vous êtes des producteurs de politique
publique en tout cas vous y contribuez
vous les accompagner et je pense qu'on a
besoin de signaux forts d'accompagnement
ça veut dire des accompagnements à la
transformation des accompagnements
agnements à la prise de risque alors
c'est pas forcément que le je dirais la
puissance publique et l'argent des
contribuables qui doit accompagner cette
prise de risque elle doit être partagée
par les acteurs on a beaucoup parlé de
la réforme de l'assurance récolte elle
est passée aussi ici donc ça fait partie
de cette logique aussi de dire imaginons
un système différent alors c'est un tout
petit c'est important mais c'est un seul
petit élément finalement de l'adaptation
c'est juste le prémunir contre les aléas
mais
la meilleure prévention contre les aléas
c'est de se mettre en sécurité
c'est-à-dire de se dire je suis moins vu
c'est réduire la vulnérabilité puisque
l'aléa il va être là il va augmenter
vraisemblablement quoi qu'on fasse dans
le domaine de l'atténuation du
changement climatique les précipitations
intenses les sécheresses vont augmenter
en intensité en fréquence probablement
pas partout pareil mais c'est comme ça
la tendance donc si on peut pas agir sur
l'aléa il faut agir sur la vulnérabilité
donc des politiques publiques qui
réduisent la vulnérabilité des
exploitants agricoles des filières
économiques mais aussi des citoyens par
rapport aux atouts c'est ça c'est très
vaste c'est systémique c'est pas que
l'on parle d'agriculture mais ça va
concerner l'énergie ça va concerner
l'eau en tant que ressource aussi pour
le consommateur mais c'est vraiment
cette vision systémique et de réduction
des vulnérabilités qui est importante et
peut-être le dernier mot puisque je sais
que tu en passes vite être toujours très
prudent par rapport à l'adaptation et ce
être gardé toujours une capacité de
gérer de se questionner en chemin
faisant parce que quand on prend des
options et qu'on se dit
on fait de la crème mentale et on
s'enfer dans une situation donc garder
de la souplesse et de la réactivité
c'est pour moi en tout cas l'une des
formes intéressantes de la résilience
par beaucoup de résilience dans plein de
domaines la résilience dans nos systèmes
agricoles agronomique alimentaire c'est
pas que maintenir coûte que coûte la
production telle qu'elle a toujours été
en mettant plus d'un an plus d'eau etc
attendez pour protéger contre la grêle
c'est de se dire je continue à produire
mais en même temps je garde une capacité
d'anticipation d'adaptation de souplesse
pour préparer le coup d'après et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on a beaucoup de
mal à faire quand on a un système qui
est établi et dans un dans des
conditions qui étaient un peu standard
si on s'éloigne de ce standard bah on
est un peu perdu et on a du mal à lâcher
parce qu'on sait pas ce qu'on va avoir
la place
avec cette sensibilité pour aller voir
justement et ils l'ont perdu
complètement parce qu'on disait
ce que fait le voisin etc or ce que vous
dit tout à l'heure c'est qu'il y a
plutôt un effet d'imitation maintenant
qui est de dire ça a marché dont je fais
la même chose et tout le monde s'en
gouffre dans la même filière
messieurs merci beaucoup je regrette
d'ailleurs qu'on se obliger de se
quitter parce que c'était vraiment très
très intéressant et en plus ça complète
la commission de ce matin sur la
biodiversité je trouve que là on a passé
à une journée vraiment enrichissante
merci beaucoup merci à vous merci